we take for granted in our lives choice
in every other area whether it's
pop-tarts or cereal or cellphones but
really education is the most important
thing especially as a parent you want
your kids to have a solid education
my name is Lisa Snell and I'm the
director of education for the reason
foundation and I've been working on
education and school choice issues for
about 20 years and probably the biggest
joy that I'm affiliated with school
choices I'm always trying to find good
choices for my own kids schools school
choice in the United States is really at
a tipping point in the sense that kids
in America have more choices today than
they've ever had before schools really
are no longer driven by where you live
in your address and residential
assignment instead you can choose a
school based on your interests and the
way that that happens is right now
there's 5,000 charter schools in the
United States serving more than 2
million kids and in some cities like Los
Angeles and New Orleans a much larger
number of kids get to go to those kinds
of schools there's also private
scholarship programs and tax credit
programs that allow you to take your
public school money to a private school
of your choice there's more than 35 of
those programs now in the United States
so across the board public schools have
because of the competition they have way
more magnet schools and they're getting
rid of residential assignments so
there's just a lot more choice it's much
better to be a kid if you want to choose
your school in 2011 number one public
schools are in for school choice because
they're now letting public dollars
follow kids to their school so public
schools have felt a lot of competition
from charter schools and school vouchers
and tax credits and school scholarships
and public schools generally have not
had school choice for every school in
their district and their financing
systems have been set up based on where
you live so you get to go to a school
based on residential assignment it's
your neighborhood school but public
schools because of competition have had
to change the way they do things by
opening up enrollment and letting the
money follow the child so even here in
California Governor Jerry Brown has just
come out with a proposal where he would
have a weighted student funding and the
state money would go where the child is
at based on the characteristics of the
individual child Governor mitch Daniels
and Indiana
just had a statewide school financing
program based on the money follow the
child and there's actually about 40
places now school districts like New
York City San Francisco Boston Chicago
where instead of having residential
assignment they actually let kids pick
the public school that they want to go
to and the district per pupil funding
follows that child to the school number
to across the country courts more and
more ruling that both vouchers and tax
credits are constitutional both state
and the Supreme Court nationally have
been siding with parents in terms
allowing them to use public dollars to
pick the school of their choice so in
April 2011 the Supreme Court voted for
example that tax credits could support
kids going to private schools because
the government never had the money in
the first place and they never were
public dollars in January of 2012
Indiana which just passed the largest
statewide voucher program in the nation
their state Supreme Court sided with
parents and said that that program was
constitutional and that it could be
expanded and kids could take vouchers in
Indiana to go to private schools
number three evidence shows that school
choice charter schools vouchers tax
credits works there's more and more
evidence that school choice works for
kids so for example in the city of New
Orleans now in 2012 about 90 percent of
kids are enrolled in charter schools and
for the last six years New Orleans has
seen very steady improvement in terms of
test scores for reading and math and
science and in terms of graduation rates
the kids are doing much better than
before they had choice and in addition
to that there were 20 studies that were
random assignment gold standard studies
that looked at the effect of vouchers
and school choice on public schools and
18 out of 19 found that public schools
perform better when they have
competition from vouchers and the 19th
study found really no difference every
empirical study in places like Milwaukee
Cleveland Florida
shows a positive
effect when it's a gold standard study
the ease randomized assignments and no
studies have found negative effects and
in addition to that they find these
positive effects for a lot less money so
school vouchers and charter schools
actually are getting the same results or
better for a much lower cost than
traditional public schools charter
schools and school vouchers are like
anything else there's good performers in
there there's bad performers but the key
difference with these kind of schools is
that they're held accountable because if
they don't succeed they lose their
funding because we're not bound to keep
that school open because of some
sentimental obligation that it's a
neighborhood school and they're
contractually obligated to serve their
students with school choice parents tend
to have much higher satisfaction they
tend to score very high on things like
safety the empirical evidence shows that
for middle schools and high schools
graduation rates are much better that
college attendance is much better so
while they may not always out score
traditional schools in terms of math and
reading there's a lot of quality of life
values that parents value that make
having the choice important to those
parents and is one of the reasons for
the popularity so for instance in New
York or LA when you have a successful
charter school you often have hundreds
of people waiting in line on waiting
lists to get into those schools and it's
because of academic performance but it's
also because of things that are harder
to quantify there's really no reason
that we should pick our k-12 schools
based on where we live instead because
of both technology and the idea that the
money should always follow the child we
can pick our schools based on the needs
of our child not on some other arbitrary
factor everything else we do we do based
on choice why not education